une impression de déjà-vu ils étaient
des milliers devant le monument national
pour lier un meilleur contrôle des armes
à feu nature idoux valdes est encore
fraîche dans les esprits et ne passe pas
le 24 mai un étudiant de 18 ans u19
écoliers 2 enseignante dans une école
primaire au texas
deux ministres cercueil dit il construit
pour des petits corps mutilé et décapité
l'image est poignante
c'est bouleversant d'hitler fall un dieu
qui est des enfants du même âge que les
victimes
il faut interdire les fusils d'assaut
dit-elle et vérifier les antécédents
c'est la base et on s'entend presque
tous là dessus
je suis une maîtresse dit elle et je
n'ai pas envie de penser à des armes à
feu en classe et je ne pas apprendre à
savoir tirer
la nr est une organisation terroriste
dit elle on doit les poursuivre ils sont
responsables de cette épidémie de
violence par armes à feu ils font de la
promotion les fabricants d'armes
continuent à inonder nos rues avec leurs
armes
il faut arracher sur des wafers tout
près du rassemblement un mémorial un
triste rappel des personnes qui sont
tombées sous les balles plus de 45000 en
2020 la moitié étaient des suicides une
fois de plus les américains lancent un
véritable cri du coeur pour mettre un
terme à toutes ces fusillades aux états
unis et j'espère que cette colère va se
traduire par une loi au congrès pour
restreindre une fois pour toutes l'accès
aux armes à feu la balle est dans le
camp du sénat plusieurs projets de loi
sont sur la table dont celui du drapeau
rouge qui permettrait la saisie
temporaire d'armes à feu lors ce qu'ils
appartiennent à une personne jugée
instable et dangereuse
j'adorais me promener dans mon quartier
dit robert g depuis que j'entends des
coups de feu je reste chez moi
pendant qu'on tergiverse au sénat ces
jeunes de 12 ans subissent l'impact de
l'inaction congrès du célèbre des gangs
hisserait du canada à washington